on se trouve deux fois sur ce [ __ ] de
fans via une mise à jour et maintenant
il ya un but du jeu et on peut jouer
freddy bonis ou foxy ok on va jouer
contre faut que c'est mon gars c'est
parti terrifiant wade ok alors collecte
les cinq objets en une minute trente
motta
au mexique d'où il était déjà là avec ce
message à abuser les ballons un [ __ ]
je l'entends attend mais à peine tu
supposes il est déjà là mais avec trop
scandaleux
super excité il est sous cocaïne [ __ ]
celle acquittée après 10 af-pak bandja
l'epide ta gueule oh vous avez vu dès
qu'ils chargent en fait je peux lui
faire peur ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
ça
et je pense le temps qu'il a vu qu'il
faut courir à temps c'est un objet non
identifié attente attente attente en
carnet argana il faut tout un marché
lumières éteintes oye-plage t'aveugle la
rétine et si quoi il faut trouver avec
les objets ressemble à quoi pitch dans
un cul de sac jaune on est foutu
claquettes aveugle et lâche pas au
courant à quoi ressemblent les objets
que doit prendre [ __ ] mais ça qu'on
veut savoir bordel qu'est pouquoi genou
deux peuples est aveugle et j'obtiens
et l'usure jc attend les oublis sont
cachés dans une autre maison en fait il
n'ya pas d'objets ok j'en vois un objet
ta gueule ta gueule tu as gueule mais il
faut que je me bats toujours
là bas qui comptent elles profitent
pétain c'est abusé il me suit à travers
le train qui la chapelle si l'auto
guider mais regarde et me dites pas
qu'il a pas un sonar quoi les y allument
toi bon tu étais
tu finir par pleurer
ok j en ai eu un [ __ ] c'est une bonne
nouvelle
bon bah oh
[ __ ] quand on vient dire maman c'est
ta gueule
avec il a voulu faire le dark souls est
chiche youtube écossais sur dia cette
lumière nt chienne m'aveugle voilà boom
foyer puis un je m'en bats les couilles
ok en fait c'est horrible je dois tout à
regarder la lampe torche éteinte parce
que le seul moyen de le repousser qu'on
est bien c'est de l'allumer en fait
alors ou sur les objets à j'en ai aucun
mec voilà ça c'en est un bébé bouge mais
t'es quoi c'est drôle mais je suis
coincé suis dans un blog mais je suis
dans un carton [ __ ] ma vie comme ça
c'est un objet ça non c'est une vieille
cage dans laquelle y avait mais pas un
make up l'acheter avec moi oh ça c'est
pas d'apprendre ça au plan de la [ __ ]
je vais devoir appuyer bloquer ces mots
sur les nationales permettent pour chris
noth qui va faire notre monstre alors
affaire boni pitel et terrifiant attend
est carrément bien cette map la panique
ont pas il nous reste que 28 secondes
pour trouver mille objets c'est pas
grave ok on peut le faire dans un
couloir mais mec c'est quoi cette cave
là donc je dois aller ok il arrive on va
se marier mais c'est de se parler je
sais pas si on peut l'aveuglé lui basile
bien je suis prêt et éclairé
est-ce qu'on était sûr et certain que ça
n'avait pas marché je préfère largement
cette mammoni je suis désolé tu fais moi
peur que ton ami foxy lie intrigue à
prendre hop et je cours je cours sans pu
m'arrêter ouais quoi tuer je me retrouve
dans cette [ __ ] de camion garé là car
elle est plus grande que la station
châtelet les halles mais que faire quoi
[ __ ] il court il court il court ico
o la technique de lâches
mais j'en peux plus là ici un truc c'est
sûr c'est sûr c'est sûr à 12,3 étagères
ya pas un objet tu me mets à le poster
la boum ok je pense que c'était mon la
ramasser mais c'est beaucoup trop dur là
le dr il a craqué sur ce type manga
au coeur et les cas c'est plutôt m ait
choisi le coeur c'est une entente et
c'est l'image qui est inversée normal je
suis très sage chute à lens pressé le
temps faire ma blague on a déjà perdu 20
secondes michael tu me fait pas peur
bâtard m'en bats les couilles de toi
prédit j'espère que tu es nul là c'est
une maison donc on peut se repérer plus
facilement à tanger toujours pas trouvé
un objet là ça fait combien de temps que
je vois la [ __ ] on en sait un cul de
sac à dos et un objet la hausse et la
casquette berné la à la technique du
coin
il a habitué à des objets ils changent
d'endroit à chaque fois c'est abusé ok
boom est de la partie là on est chaud il
en est on fire mon gain
ok on se bat on est au nice maintenant
pas ceux qui parlent pas anglais
comprendront la blague ça va les amuser
ici un truc ouailles après mais on est
même perçue et les souks au comic con
vita était tous prennent de la drogue là
c'est mal ok oye si on a un direct la
[ __ ] c'est notre chance mec mais non
mais non ok on appris un truc en passant
c'est génial au québec on a appris à
trouver bien c'est autre chose plus que
2 4 aux mondiaux dans sa que tak allez
je te plaît 5t août et où le sac je te
plaît montre toi mec qui te plaît
pourquoi t'es cruel 6 secondes pour le
trouver cinq secondes 3 secondes pour
arrimer la vidéo way adresse d'une
prochaine merci d'avoir regardé portez
vous bien injustement bis
[Musique]
oh